over the last few years i've launched
five art competitions and now the
incredible art from those competitions
has a home
soul arts a beautiful tone carefully
crafted and full of art inspired by
demon souls dark souls blood-borne
sakura and eldon ring to be clear the
book has no official link to these games
but that's exactly what makes the art
within it so creative these artists
imagined places bosses and weapons that
have never been visualized before
expanding the worlds that we love in an
exceptional way
go beyond the sixth hearthstone and read
about the twisted city where the weaver
gently distorts the world we'll skip
ahead to the unseen lands where artists
brought to life regions that we never
got to see in game few would have seen
this piece from the imagining bloodborne
2 competition which depicts carol's
terrible fate nor this piece of
prosthetic art where secure becomes
equipped with a pivoting greatsword then
there's the chapter for eldon ring with
bosses and open worlds drawn from a time
where we knew absolutely nothing about
the game so
we'd be honored if soul arts could earn
a place on your bookshelf or coffee
table
this kickstarter is a real leap of faith
but with your help i know that we can
create something that you will come to
treasure here's a preview of your reward
tiers a digital edition
a cover art poster by ricardo amike
the art book itself the art book with
the slip case an art exhibition bundle
featuring a collage poster the
benefactor bundle where your name will
be listed at the back of the book and a
signed edition from me
i'll be back at the end of the video but
for now i'm going to pass over to jason
our publisher who is going to explain
things in a bit more detail
hi everyone this is jason from tune in
fairweather
let me tell you about soul arts this is
the most ambitious project that we have
worked on
to date
we always try to push ourselves with
each new project and with this one we're
going into a much larger format
10 inches by 12 inches this is a
giant book it's going to be
unmissable
256 pages
of vibrant
full color artwork
dozens of different artists
lots of different styles you are not
going to get bored
flipping through this book
every page is
a new unexpected
fever dream
inspired by the games of brim software
you're going to love it it's been so
much fun to work on there are so many
unique styles represented we have
there's pixel art there is lush
colorful digital painting techniques on
show
there are grim hyper realistic
character concepts and so to not just
have those inspiring visuals but also
have it in
a lavish
physical tangible form is really
important to us
we want to honor
the artists that are part of this book
and honor this series with with
something that is collectible that's
going to stand the test of time and so
one of the new challenges uh that we're
taking on with this project is to not
just deliver a beautiful book but to
have
a
gorgeous protective slip case to house
your investment this is
custom designed by our art director
andrew hind
we created a die cut
viewing portal in the front of
the
slip case so that you get this keyhole
glimpse of ricardo emig's um
cover art which we're referring to as
canvas of souls since
uh you have this abstraction of all of
these different artists jostling and to
draw their own unique vision onto this
ethereal
canvas
the design finishes on this book
are absolutely immaculate
from the moment you turn the front cover
open and you're confronted with the
metallic gold
end paper design
you can already
start seeing
symbols that are custom designed
to match each one of the five art
contests
and so they each
create this constellation when they all
fit together so because of the
ambitious nature of this project we want
to work with a print partner
that we have a lot of trust with and so
we're working with conti tip of color
again
they were the
printer based in florence italy that
helped us bring you died to life and
we threw everything at them we did four
different versions of that book and they
absolutely nailed
every single
piece of it so we feel very confident
that that they will
help us deliver
to the absolute highest standard
with this particular project
and we've already been in touch with
them even ahead of the campaign to start
showing them some of the target visuals
and they are very excited about it and
can't wait to get going we've got lots
of fun rewards
to offer as part of this campaign we
realize that the physical version of
soul arts is a big financial investment
so we're happy to be offering a digital
edition at a lower price
that is high resolution drm free
no shipping cost so it's a great option
if you want to enjoy sole arts but
aren't quite ready to
back at a higher tier
we have not one but two different art
prints this time
one
a
larger format version of the cover
artwork for you to display on your wall
and then the idea for the second print
which is a design showcase is to take
the book and distill it down so that you
get a kind of gallery exhibition
within the confines of that frame and
we're really proud of how this one
turned out so we hope you like it if
you'd like to have your name
immortalized in the acknowledgement
section of soul arts have a look at the
benefactor bundle um
that's a way of
us being able to thank
some of our more generous contributors
for helping us bring this project to
life and then for
people who have been following vati's
work for years
and want to have his personalized touch
featured in their book we're going to
have
uh signed nameplates that you'll be able
to
affix to the endpapers of the book and
have been designed to
fit perfectly in that space complemented
by the
the
you know metallic gold
background there thank you so much for
watching this video
and thanks again to all of the artists
represented in this book we hope you are
proud of the way that we've showcased
your art
and
we think this will be an absolute
essential
collectible for
anybody who loves the games of from
software and feels that inspiration well
up when they play them
you cannot look through this book
without feeling the incredible
overwhelming sense of
love and appreciation that the artists
represented here
have for these games and it just oozes
off every page we've still got a lot of
work ahead of us before we're able to
finalize the layout of soul arts and
send it to the printer so we're
targeting early 2022 for the shipping of
the physical edition and the digital
edition will go out ahead of that as
soon as it's ready so you'll have that
to tease you as you're awaiting the
finished product
share the campaign with a friend we need
your support
to make this happen if you want to go on
this journey with us
we would love to have you
and uh thanks for being part of this we
really appreciate you bye i have my two
copies of jason's book you died here and
i'm just so excited at the prospect of
having a book that looks and feels as
good as this one jason put a lot of work
into this book and it shows he and i
both believe strongly in having a few
really special things that you can
collect and treasure it's better to have
a few things that bring you a lot of joy
rather than a lot of things that don't
right for me personally though just
bringing soul arts into existence will
bring me a lot of joy because whenever i
released an art competition video there
were always tons of artists who just
missed out on being featured and
having to make those decisions tormented
me the video would have had to be hours
and hours long to include everyone and
video isn't the best medium for
presenting artwork it just isn't but a
book is and with this we'll be able to
feature new artists and move away from
the competition aspect so that we can
just focus purely on the art and the
narratives that are being presented and
of course most artworks submitted did
come with gameplay descriptions and a
story sometimes as well so i've taken
that text and those stories and i've
faithfully rewritten every single entry
so that every entry sounds consistent
between pages because every artist
writes differently and now it's all
being rewritten through my hand so it
can also fit the page perfectly as well
when necessary i'm also expanding upon
these stories with writing of my own and
it's my hope that each page will read
like a short prepared story so if you're
a fan of the channel i think you're
going to love that aspect so there have
been five competitions and across those
competitions winning artists have
already received their share of ten
thousand dollars in total now while 99
of artists that i contacted for the book
gave me permission to include their art
without any mention of payment or a fee
i've decided to also split another 10k
of my own money for every artist that
was shortlisted for the book that money
is already sent and it's theirs to keep
even if their artwork isn't chosen for
the final book or even if the project
doesn't get funded for whatever reason
paying artists properly is really
important to me and the book has made
that possible and if the project does
get funded then the publisher has also
committed to shipping a free copy to all
included artists as well
of course names of included artists will
be presented alongside their entries and
links to their portfolios will be found
at the end of the book for anyone keen
to seek them out and commission them or
send them job offers so as you can
probably tell this is a book with no
compromise because i strongly believe
that the art is worthy of that i'm aware
that doesn't come cheap but you get what
you pay for and i hope that you can join
me in supporting this kickstarter before
the campaign ends
if this is a success then it will also
help to fund future art competitions so
that we can make the souls art community
the strongest of them all thank you as
always for your support
it means everything to me
you